[Applaudissements]
voilà alors vous un petit bisou pas
continue mais une musique tous faim qui
s'est alors amené japonais j'ai
l'impression d'être devant une vitrine
de pâtisserie à tout va et goûter
[Applaudissements]
calais daniel qui viennent me dire un
truc que je trouve à midi daniel j'adore
cette émission la petite emilie n'a pu
ne m'avait bien promis trois poils de
son cul pour faire un tapis y ait tant
pis mais quand on est habillé coutu la
petite emilie la plus lookée voilà
c'était jean dutourd est mort
ça chauffe et j'ai envie de me
rapprocher de quelqu'un et puis sur la
droite
voila voila c est quand même je sais pas
et je penche vaille est d'accord c'est
vraiment hormonal mais aussi pensez vous
dansez a pas du tout non je vis avec ma
mère dans un très vieil appartement dans
la chanson de michel
voilà je sens qu'on a on qu'on a du
feeling même si vous ne sentez pas
encore je suis toujours un petit peu en
avance donc je compte sur vous pour me
lever au propre comme au figuré parce
que je suis pas sûr que je vais pouvoir
me relever là j'espère vous faire
craquer au moins autant que mes genoux
crack en ce moment voilà donc cédé
jean-michel voulez vous coucher avec moi
c'est ce qu'a dit
[Applaudissements]